Meryl Streep's actually cool this
happened today we've offhandledly call
Meryl the goat I keep saying oh and you
know getting to work with Meryl she's
the goat she's the goat right you know
like oh go do that yeah the goat will go
here which if you know stands for
greatest of all time right and we were
doing a photo shoot and I you know said
something like goat and and Meryl kind
of said that's right just tell the Old
Goat where to go and then today we're
doing a press conference and she's like
you know and Jonah is so comfortable
with me he's been calling me a goat all
week and
um and I'm like what the and I was like
Meryl you know that goat means greatest
of all time right and she was like oh no
and Jennifer Lawrence explained to her
because she was telling Jennifer about
this how she and she's so cool she
wasn't even offended by it well we
haven't just been calling you ghosts
shout out to the goats